it's just like how you said like well
why would someone pick you when there's
other options in terms of like it's the
same thing with like lifestyle like I
might not I might go down in lifestyle
from me being able to travel twice a
month to Mexico and la and do all of
that
but I'm not and I'm not spending as much
money we're not going out maybe we do
like once a month a family dinner that
goes out like or something like that I
could easily do that but do I want to go
back to like a struggling situation or
where it's like we're pinching pennies I
don't think so
people just don't go down in Lifestyles
willingly they don't and you know this
if you've had a business and had
employees you might have an employee
that's not performing but the last thing
you can do is give them a demotion you
can't I'm going to cut your pay you
don't follow them
yeah so you know we're kind of being a
little Cavalier saying yeah I'll just go
down in life well these are hypothetical
this is also would I be doing this we
want to tell the truth just because I
haven't thought about doesn't mean so
this in this hypothetical scenario I'm
picturing like something happened to a
job or like there's unemployment and we
have to make these cuts
um I don't think I would necessarily go
into a relationship knowing I would have
to raise a family on 45 how about this
is just the average guy but he would
make a good husband and a family you
know maybe yeah getting close to
geriatric practices I don't know and
you're just we're thinking you know what
it's time to settle down
the rich men aren't biting this he's a
good guy
he's he's a good guy you know what I'm
gonna just go down on lifestyle so we
can have a family
uh no
I wouldn't want to raise my kids to have
a similar upbringing as me or we had to
be stressed where I had to as a child
worry about foreclosure and making sure
that I was working so that my family
wouldn't have to cover like School
expenses or or field trips like I don't
want my kids to have to experience that
I think so I wouldn't have a family what
if it was
because the lady I'm thinking of she
just lives in less than ten thousand
dollars a month like her husband like
let's say you have enough money for
savings and like you can put 20 of your
income away but you have to stay below
she lived last month less she got less
than less than ten thousand a month oh
yeah sorry for the kids a year
between the two parties or just her
um like raising the kids household
because she wouldn't have kids yeah I
don't think I would have kids
this is crazy her husband makes six
figures she's gonna do an episode of
wife school to show how she like how she
lives so cheap
so she said so you saying that her
disposable income they just save it yeah
but I'm telling you like she sent me
videos of how they live they just look I
couldn't live like that they also don't
want to raise my kids spoiled I think
that there's definitely something I
learned coming from a family that didn't
have money like a different kind of work
ethic I tried really hard in high school
as a result I don't think I would have
tried as hard if my family wasn't like
struggling but I think with like having
my biggest thing if I'm going to have
kids is giving them the best lifestyle
that they can have and the like the
least amount of like worry and I think
often when families are going through
financial difficulty or like whatever it
is even if they're keeping it from their
kids like the kids pick up on that kids
are smart and they feel that they can
feel the pressure maybe like the parents
are now a little bit more stressed that
that affects the children and like their
growth and I don't want to put that on
my kids well let me let me ask you all
the question though okay so you want the
life I mean let's be clear like you want
the life you want to fly here and there
you want to have nice cars you want to
be able to go shop over in the Design
District I mean right it sounds good
though in an Ideal World
not yet but that's what you want though
right yeah yeah but I don't need it cool
I'm with that right
so you meet this guy and he has the
ability to be able to give you that
what separates you from any other girl
that would validate him actually giving
you that lifestyle why would he give you
that
versus giving somebody else that or I
make a sandwich
it's a lot of girls that make sandwiches
and get phenomenal
I mean the sandwiches
but I mean for real like what what would
why would he choose you my Kick-Ass
personality and your personality and
loyalty
Anton what do you what do you think the
answer should be to that
um what should what should women bring
to the table um
I'ma just be honest honestly I mean I
was with the sandwich honestly
um I think that if a guy reaches a
certain status in life
and he's not young right let's just say
he's above the age of 33 34 years old
right
um I don't see why he would choose
any woman to marry
once he reaches a certain threshold
interesting I don't see why he would
choose any of them you think you should
want the connection I think men want he
can have a commit connection with as
many women as he wants but that a deep
connection and intimacy and like real
like stress you can't get that with
anyone you're not going to get that why
can't you she's gonna suck your dick and
then leave and then be not you know what
I mean you're not having that
communication you're not building
something men want I don't really think
you understand men no I think she's the
right thing no the majority of men
listen I've taught the majority of them
in my whole Adult Career I coach him
every day lead I I disagree you know do
you coach like the the guys who are
really trying to get it or do you coach
the average man how much I think that
how how much are your coaching sessions
they're a lot they're a lot are they
over a thousand I don't wanna I don't
want to say it online okay if there's a
lot then that by definition means that
you're not coaching the average man
because the average man can't afford it
so don't tell me you coach the average
man because it's not true but I Mentor
yada a lot of guys and I knew that the
coaching the coaching is different than
the mentor right don't in fact coach
that no no no but see here's the here's
the caveat though lead because the
coaching session no no I'm gonna add the
contact you coach I'm gonna add the
contacts if you don't no no no I have a
certain amount of slots
that are a lot for regular people
yeah pretty much right but and those are
the regular guys so the coaching
sessions is completely different from
the guys that you allocate a specific
amount of your time to be able to hear
from regular people because I don't want
to become so disconnected that's true
but the charity cases are a small
percentage because you don't have a lot
of time that's true but I do I do talk
to a lot of guys though
it's hard to some regular dudes right I
get it I get it but what I'm saying is
what she's saying is is is is the fact
most guys really want a connection with
a woman it's true but that's not what we
talking about she's specifically no she
the question was when you reach a
certain threshold the type of guys that
they want they want the top one percent
you speaking about regular guys
they're saying I want guys that make 150
000 or more
a guy that's 20 years old on average is
not making 150 000 a year
when you start to get to a certain
threshold because most guys just making
a type of money are well into their
careers or they're they're starting to
get into that as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible